you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's program
north sea oil and gas companies set for
near record income should they pay to
ease the cost of living crisis
one of scotland's two nuclear power
stations is decommissioned after 46
years
and the climate scientists living at the
heart of the colorado community ripped
apart by wildfires
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now oil and gas companies operating in
the north sea are set to see near record
income in 2021 and 22 as international
energy prices rocket it's led to calls
for a windfall tax to be levied on the
firms which could be used to ease the
cost of living crisis faced by consumers
and as the companies continue to exploit
the north seas resources campaigners
have warned of the detrimental effect on
the climate our climate change
correspondent hannah thomas peter
reports
the cost of living crisis means
manchester-based john lloyd and kevin
doherty are already making difficult
choices
after years of homelessness they have
just enough cash to live independently
in their own home but if their energy
bills skyrocket as predicted they'll be
back on the streets
it makes reports of record profits for
oil and gas companies driven by those
high energy prices hard to stomach
it's a shame on society i mean these
people
they have no idea what it's like to live
how we're living at the moment there's
people out there who've got children who
are really struggling
or how they survive it's profits before
people yeah
a recent report from energy consultancy
wood mckenzie predicts that oil and gas
companies in the uk's north sea alone
will announce near record cash flows of
around 12.5 billion pounds in 2021 and
13.3 billion in 2022.
those are levels that haven't been seen
since the boom years preceding the 2008
financial crisis
europe's biggest oil and gas group is
among those benefiting
shell has just announced soaring profits
mainly as a result of high gas prices
and it's the kind of thing that will
only strengthen calls for the government
to impose a windfall tax on the fossil
fuel industry
that idea has caused a row the companies
involved argue that existing tax
arrangements are enough
given the extraordinary price rise for
energy and the pain for uk consumers
why shouldn't you be asked to pay a
little bit more in the form of a
windfall tax in doing so you really
disturb the investments in uk makers
less competitive
drive jobs energy and security supply
out of the uk and that really isn't no
one's benefits you know please we you
know we acknowledge we pay more tax we
want that to happen
and we want those monies to go where the
most needed
campaigners say that's nonsense and the
only solution is an even faster switch
to renewables
you cannot reconcile the fact that the
uk is the second largest oil and gas
producer in europe and the fact that the
government claims to be a climate leader
and to have a net zero aspiration i mean
there is no net zero future where we are
continuing to encourage production of
oil and gas it's as simple as that
as long as fossil fuel companies are
making money in the north sea those
tensions will continue
net zero carbon emissions by 2050 was
never going to be easy but the energy
crisis is making a hard job
even more so
hannah thomas peter sky
news after 46 years scotland's hunters
and b nuclear power station was
decommissioned today when operating at
full capacity it was capable of
providing enough low carbon electricity
to power 1.7 million homes
now at its peak in the 1990s nuclear
power provided about a quarter of the
uk's electricity needs you can see on
our data dashboard that the proportion
has fallen as i speak to you nuclear
power is providing just over 11
of the country's electricity with gas at
38 percent and renewables mostly wind at
33
now nuclear power is expensive and
results in dangerous toxic waste but it
doesn't release carbon emissions so is a
valuable part of the low carbon mix as
the country aims to be net zero by 2050.
skies james matthews reports now from
north asia
from the airship coast comes a winter's
tale about change
change in the energy landscape
and in the landscape itself
[Applause]
when hunters nuclear power stations
spewed steam on friday at midday it was
breathing its last
the steam that once drove its turbines
won't anymore hunterston is closing down
the overwhelming feeling is winner pride
we've been generating electricity for 46
years providing scotland with a quarter
of his electricity needs and that's low
carbon electricity
hunterson b has generated electricity
for 46 years way beyond its expected
lifespan
its closure has been brought forward
after hairline cracks developed in
graphite bricks inside the reactor
proponents of the nuclear power industry
say losing it will mean higher energy
costs and greater reliance on imported
fossil fuels
opponents see it differently over the
period where hunters have been having so
many problems scotland's massively
growing its renewables capacity which
means the reality is that now the
hunters close we won't really be needing
that electricity
anyway in the future so we're moving on
to using far more renewables
hunterston is a human story too of
hundreds whose working lives were spent
here some came back to bid farewell sad
pretty sad actually
nobody lovely place to work great time
at the power station so many people who
were very very
committed it was exciting too it was the
forefront really yes
it was very very exciting
diggy graham will be among a majority of
staff involved in a defueling process
lasting three years a long goodbye to a
long career that started aged 15. when
you think of the the
carbon emissions saving i think that's
equivalent to taking every car in
scotland off the road for 19 years so
you put any contacts like that it's
quite staggering
the end of hunterston will leave torness
on scotland's east coast as its only
remaining nuclear power station although
torn s2 is on the way out on this
industry on this side of the uk border
the sun is setting
james matthews sky news north ayrshire
well in some of today's other climate
news the chief executive of centrica the
owner of british gas has called for
green levees on energy bills to be
scrapped to help customers facing higher
energy prices currently about 12 percent
of gas and electricity bills go towards
funding green energy programs the
company argues that this funding should
come from general taxation rather than
taxes on energy use
an increase in gas prices has triggered
violent protests in kazakhstan and the
social unrest has in turn led to an
increase in the price of uranium crucial
to the production of nuclear power the
strategically important central asian
country is the source of 40
of the world's uranium supplies and the
10th largest producer of coal
poland's ambassador to the czech
republic has been sacked following
comments about a controversial coal mine
bordering the two countries ambassador
miroslav yazinski said poland had showed
a lack of will to ease tensions over the
mine after czech authorities said it
negatively affects the environment and
drains water from local villages poland
has refused to close the vast touro mine
despite being ordered to do so by the
european court of justice
japan's biggest power generator says it
will spend almost half a billion pounds
on the development of ammonia related
technology ammonia is seen as an
important future energy source because
like hydrogen it doesn't emit carbon
dioxide when it's burnt the company jira
plans to invest in new ways of producing
ammonia with the ultimate aim of
replacing the use of coal in power
generation
answer david attenborough has lent his
voice to a special episode of the
children's show hey dougie to show the
importance of plants the naturalist has
joined with regular narrator alexander
armstrong for the programme in which he
explains how trees and plants are the
basis of all life on earth
president biden and his wife are due to
land shortly in colorado to examine the
damage caused by wildfires on december
the 30th now the fires whipped through
the suburbs driven by winds of over a
hundred miles an hour and exacerbated by
months of drought boulder colorado is
also home to many of america's leading
climate scientists we spoke to one who
is still coming to terms with being at
the center of what she believes is a
climate change-induced disaster
this is our community and to watch it
burn so quickly is something that i
think we're all just struggling to
believe and understand i shouldn't be
talking about wildfires
in the middle of winter
makes you want to choke up and cry it's
like
christmas just passed and then
you know everything that they went
through is just gone
[Music]
the first sign that i had that something
was wrong was seeing smoke filling up
into the sky late morning
you know when i saw the color of that
smoke i and i knew that structures were
burning
you know my heart just sank
[Music]
that night kind of walked out
to a hill behind my home i literally see
homes burning
and it's just a very
heavy feeling it's devastating and this
is nothing less than a disaster for our
community
[Music]
it's one thing to study these fires i've
been a fire scientist for 20 years and
it's another thing to see
a fire in my own backyard and impacting
my own community
i have staff who've lost homes i have
friends and colleagues who've lost homes
this has been a really challenging time
for us
[Music]
so what climate change does for fires is
it sets the stage it takes just a little
bit of warming to lead to a lot more
burning
[Music]
i've never been so happy to see snow in
my in my life to put out that fire but
it's very unusual
for
us climate scientists be talking about
snow putting out fire that's only
happened one other time in my career
and if this isn't a smoking gun for
climate change i don't know what is it's
scary because it seems like colorado
weather just keeps getting more and more
wild like this the 100 mile an hour
winds that we had yesterday i don't
remember having that years ago it's
definitely seems like it's gotten a lot
worse lately
[Music]
many of us now would consider ourselves
climate refugees
and we're all asking ourselves how many
warming related disasters do we need
before we see real proactive action
have a look at this an artist has carved
the word chile in large blocks of ice
and has placed it in santiago's forestar
park
to throw a spotlight on the climate
crisis the artist daniel reyes is
calling for the protection of the
environment in the country's new
constitution which is currently being
drafted
now do stay tuned because coming up here
on the daily climate show i'll be joined
by climate activist laura young and
professor of political economy at the
university of sheffield michael jacobs
and we're going to be discussing whether
oil and gas companies should pay a
winful tax to help counter rising energy
costs and
if the january can help people make real
lifestyle changes see you in a moment
and welcome back to the daily climate
show here on sky news and we're getting
straight to discussing the climate
issues of the day with climate activist
laura young and professor of political
economy at the university of sheffield
michael jacobs there they are now
earlier on in the show we heard how
north sea oil and gas companies are
expected to make near record profits
this year campaigners and opposition
politicians are calling on the
government to step in and implement a
windfall tax which could help pay
towards consumers rocketing energy bills
but oil and gas uk the industry's
leading trade association has warned
that this could reduce the amount of
money that the companies are able to
spend on decarbonizing their operations
so what steps if any should be taken
let's ask lauren michael um
good evening thank you so much to both
of you for joining us uh laura let's
start with you to tax or not to tax what
do you think
to tax definitely i think it's important
for us to recognize that a windfall tax
is not a new thing it has been across
all governments and we've seen them in
history before when we've had situations
like this with unprecedented profits in
different businesses and i think the
most important thing we should be
thinking about when talking about taxing
or not taxing is thinking about the
people who are going to be most affected
and when we think about the crisis that
we've been in with energy prices it is
regular people who are having to make
the decision between food or between
heating their home and that's something
that is not just and that's not thinking
about the just transition so i am in the
tax bracket i guess you could say where
we need to be taking these unprecedented
profits that we've seen and putting it
back into building up sustainable
infrastructure thinking about insulation
thinking about winter breaks and
thinking about being able to help people
afford heating their homes especially
this winter and i think it's about a
just transition for regular people and
then of course still encouraging the
fossil fuel industry to be making the
transition to renewables with the other
profits that they still make as well
okay michael what do you think because
you've actually helped draw up windfall
taxes in the past haven't you
yes i was involved uh when i was a
special adviser to gordon brown at the
treasury in 2005 in a windfall profits
tax which gordon brown as chancellor
imposed on the oil companies who again
at that point were making
very high profits
and we specifically used the money the
labor government used the money to
increase the amount of grant that was
going to elderly people on low incomes
to help them insulate
and warm their homes and that is very
much the proposal that is now being made
with regards to the oil companies now
the point of uh these profits the the
thing that's really important to
remember is that they're not a result of
any effort uh or activity at all by the
oil and gas companies
they're simply the reduction uh they're
simply the the the uh product of the
general increase in oil prices largely
because of supply chain issues by
restricted production by opec and so on
so the companies haven't earned these
profits they weren't expecting to get
these profits and therefore that's the
reason why many economists would say
when profits like these are made it is
reasonable to tax them the critical
point of course is what would then be
done with the money if the money is then
just generally brought into the
government well that's good for the
government uh uh no doubt but we are of
course about to see a huge rise in
domestic and indeed industrial and
commercial energy bills
when the price cap is raised in april
precisely because of these high oil and
gas prices on the international market
that's why we're all going to see these
energy price rises so that's why the
obvious thing to do is to take some
windfall tax from these companies and
put it directly towards reducing
people's energy bills
and i would say also helping to insulate
homes because that of course is the
long-run solution to the kind of fuel
poverty that we see so widely today we
need to have much better insulated homes
so that we don't spend as much money on
energy
well the arguments against the tax um
some of them are that it will it will
deal a blow to investor confidence in
the uk's north sea and also that if
you're cutting that money it will then
cut the amount of money that these
companies are able to use in
decarbonizing themselves so laura what
do you make of that
i think this is when we need to remind
ourselves about a just transition and
when we talk about transitioning over to
green clean renewable energy system we
can't be leaving consumers and regular
people behind and that is who has the
short end of the stick when we think
about this and that are the people those
are the people who can't turn on their
heating because of these prices and so i
just don't think that's a good enough
argument and i think we need to be
seeing the progress quicker and they've
got the infrastructure they already have
the resources and they need to be doing
it out of their own pockets as well
okay well let's uh leave tax there and
move to something else because it is
january and veganuary has risen in
popularity since it was introduced back
in 2014 with an estimated 580 000 people
giving up meat and dairy this january un
experts say switching to a plant-based
diet will significantly reduce your
climate impact but how much of a
difference can
v ganyary really make
so let's start with you michael what do
you think first of all are you have you
signed up to be january
uh i haven't but i specifically but i uh
have cut down on my meat consumption
hugely over recent years i'm not quite
vegetarian but i'm uh quite close to it
uh now and that's partly because my
children have all gone vegetarian or
nearly all of them um and because we
found it just more healthy to eat less
meat as well as for environmental
reasons and i think i'm like many people
who are eating less meat the scientific
facts are pretty clear which is that the
world uses a huge amount of the
available land uh on which we can grow
food to feed animals
and when that those animals are then
turned into food for people um it's much
less efficient and and we in a sense
waste a huge amount of land that could
be available to grow people uh grow food
for people uh growing food for for
animals and in doing so we're then
destroying nature in order to create uh
those food uh that food production so
the environmental case for eating less
meat is very strong my own view is that
uh is that if the ganuri
helps people uh do that then it's a very
good idea we're very social animals we
like to do things that other people are
doing it's easier if they're if we can
experiment with changed lifestyles this
is after all really a matter of changing
our habits many people have already done
that many more say they would like to
and i'm sure uh the ganuri is a way of
helping people change their habits in
that way
what do you think laura do you think
people who actually do it for a month
then go on to say oh well that was easy
i'll do it for the rest of the year
i think it's a tone and maybe people
will pick up a few more recipes or a few
more brands that they would love to try
for the rest of the year i know
particularly lots of new things as well
come out for veganuary so there's lots
of different products to try from every
supermarket and then lots of restaurants
as well which is great but hopefully
people will also see that throughout the
year the seasons will change and
particularly when we think about britain
january is not our best month for what
we grow but hopefully as people enter
into some of the summer months and maybe
towards august where we have bumper
harvests of things that we grow here in
britain they'll also be able to embrace
different types of vegetarian or vegan
foods and be able to be inspired to pick
this up throughout the year and maybe
carry on some bits and i know lots of
people who have stuck at it for the
whole of january before and then they
might not have gone fully vegan but
they've definitely changed and made
lifestyle swaps and that's probably what
the main point is to get people thinking
and get people changing and doing it
together for a bit of fun as well
michael what do you think do you think
we should be promoting this kind of
thing throughout the year not just in
january say asking people to you know
not eat meat for one day a week just
briefly
um i think many people are calling for
that
and so this isn't simply about uh one
month it is about uh changing our eating
habits in general and any ways in which
people can cut their meat consumption
will help the planet there's no doubt
about that
okay thank you so much michael and laura
thank you so much for talking to us
now do you remember that you can also
listen to our weekly podcast climatecast
which is available now wherever you get
your podcasts
this week we take a look ahead to the
year ahead and ask will 2021 be the year
of real climate action
thank you for watching and i'll see you
next time
[Music]